- Always pay attention
to the person that's giving
the advice, not the advice.
What up, what up?
- Pleasure, man.
- How are you?
- I'm real good.
- I'm excited, I'm happy to meet you.
- I appreciate that.
What's up, my guy?
- [Neil] How you doing?
Neil.
- Neil.
- These are my homies.
- How you doing, man?
- How are you?
Tommy, Tommy?
- I'm Lavard.
- Lavard, what's up, man man?
Real pleasure.
I like your shoes, man.
- [Mike] This is like literally
one of the most excited
I've been for this meeting.
- Why is that, boy?
- Because I really believe in this guy.
He was literally just teaching us,
he has a class that he is teaching,
he wants to take everywhere.
He took the class,
he's teaching people how to make money,
he makes a ton of money himself.
He went to Complex Con, showed
up, bought one pair of shoes,
made $7,000--
- [Raks] One of five.
- One of five.
He knows what he's doing
and he wants to take it across the country
and teach these young kids
and he, literally I gave him a pen,
he just ran me right through it.
He wants to teach them how
to use their money right,
use little money, teach
them how to make the flips.
He's really paying it back.
- Independent industry
because it gets a negative stigma
that a lot of times, I know
I've heard it personally,
just on social media
that like, you're a stupid kid
that stands outside of a store for hours.
That's so dumb for sneakers.
Why would you do that?
- Let's start there
before we go further.
I'm excited for this too.
- Yeah, yeah.
- First of all, the most
interesting part about that
is and?
- Thank you, that's what
I say, that's what I say.
I agree.
- My biggest thing is on that,
for everybody, and obviously you know
I have a lot of love
for the resale game too,
the whole thing is so crazy for me,
I mean just so crazy
that everything that I was as a kid
that made no fucking,
if you understood
how off the fucking
reservation I was as a kid,
I'm a normal guy so I had
friends and everything
but I was so different,
like to the extreme,
like pretty girls liked me in high school
and I didn't want to talk to them
'cause I wanted to go to Kmart
and buy Shaquille Oneal figures
to sell on the flea market on Saturday.
So my big thing on that is, on that,
is like who gives a fuck
what people's opinions are?
It's so funny, I'm a winner
and when I drive to the
airport at 5:30 in the morning
and I am like, ugh, and I
look outside and see a line,
I'm like winners.
I swear on my fucking children,
that's what goes right through my head.
I look, I'm like, winners, right?
Remember, what year did you
and AJ start college, '05?
- Yeah, '05.
- Before yourgrillz.com,
do you remember we had a site
called bapethebathingape.com?
Remember that?
Didn't you and AJ come down
to the first Bape store
in Soho when it opened?
- [Mike] Yeah, I was obsessed with Bape
and then me and AJ came
down and bought some
on Green Street.
- Okay, 93 Green, it's still there.
- That's where it opened first.
I remember when it opened.
Yeah, I'm with you--
- Because at the end of the day,
like you said, winners,
those same kids
that are getting up at five
o'clock in the morning--
- I want to hire all of them.
- Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
- Those are the only
ones I want to talk to.
Like if you got an A in science,
I don't want to talk to you
but if you woke up at 6:15 in the morning
and you figured out how to pay off the guy
at the fucking front.
- [Mike] This is the number
one guy in the whole field.
- Let me ask you a question.
What do you want to happen?
- I want to--
- No, I'm talking macro for
you selfishly, not selflessly.
- You mean selfishly?
- Yes, selfishly.
- I want to impact as many
people as I possibly can
and basically be like, "That guy Raks was,
"he dictated long resale."
- Don't sell it then.
- You don't think?
- Not when that's what you just told me
that's what you want.
- I mean but I'm also looking at--
- Uh huh, so let's keep playing,
that's why I got excited.
- But I'm also looking
at it from a standpoint
of impact is more important to me
than like having the monetary value.
- So don't sell it.
- But how will I get it out then?
- If it's free, more
people are gonna come.
- Okay, that makes sense, that makes sense
because I can get an investment from,
okay I see where you going with that.
- I know where I'm going.
- I see where you going with that, okay.
- Let's play, right?
I understand but what I need to know
is what you want to happen.
So the thing that's interesting about you
and why I stood up and got excited
and just did my little thing
is 'cause I think we have
a lot of similarities.
I already knew and I
knew a little something
but I can smell,
the reason I do what I do
is I have to touch shit.
The reason I was bad at school,
I have to touch, this whole company sucks,
I built a $200 million company
but I had to do it, do all the
shit that comes along with it
'cause I got to touch shit.
You have the ability to make money,
that's the point of the course in itself.
- Correct.
- That means your dangerous
when it comes to content.
See the thing that's dangerous about me
compared to all the other
motivational inspiring people
is I don't want your money
'cause I know how to make money elsewhere
which means it's the reason
I'm impacting the most people.
Because money does two
things for the course,
one it's a financial barrier.
The people we're talking about,
there's a lot of people
that 250 is real money, number one,
especially if like, if the attraction is,
you know this is a game that's
great to start that process.
This is not for millionaires,
this is not for my employees,
no it is, but you know what I mean,
especially because, you
have a great point there
which is time arbitrage.
This is a great game.
One thing I was always bad at
and I'm still bad it
and I turned it into my strength
is I don't manage my time well
which weirdly worked out for me in the end
because I still continue to
give love when I shouldn't be
but what's really
interesting to me about you
is money does two
things, Raks, two things.
One, it's a restriction twice,
one, it's money and that's
a percentage of people
and especially with your flavor,
it's gonna be a restriction
to a good percentage of your audience.
Number two, for the rest
of them that can afford it,
for more than half of them,
it puts you in a box.
The box, you're full of
shit, I don't believe you,
you're just doing this
'cause you want my 250
and that just leaves you
with 20% of the 100% that
you're trying to reach, the end.
(laughing)
And you know what's been so fun,
I was a whiz kid my whole life, right,
$3,000 selling baseball
cards when I was 12,
went into my daddy's liquor
store and fucking blew it up,
I'm starting to make that transition
where I get to be the old guy.
It's fucking rewarding as fuck
because that moment, that double
smile for me, it's the best
'cause I know I'm right
and I know you know I'm right.
Now, if you now backtrack and say,
"Listen Gary, cool but
honestly on a real kick,
"of course I want to inspire
"but I feel great about selling for 250
"'cause what I'm doing is, that's a deal,
"it's worth 5,000."
You can tell me anything,
nothing makes me upset, nothing.
People can tell me anything,
really, I don't think,
who the fuck am I to judge
anybody about anything?
I mean that for real,
it's why I like everybody
'cause I don't like anybody
and I love everybody,
it's the same shit,
my opinion doesn't matter, kind of,
you know what I mean, it's just humility,
like who am I to judge?
But this is why in these,
this is what we really
need to think about.
So let me explain.
The other part that comes along
with the advice I'm giving you
is a totally different upside.
$250 a head,
even if it becomes 2,000 a head
'cause everybody's winning,
times 10,000 people,
still 100,000, real money,
wealth, mansions, life,
still falls short if you're good enough
if you give it all away for free
because then where your
life ends up when you're 52
is you actually own Supreme or Puma.
- Okay.
- 'Cause you build the biggest audience.
- Right.
And I mean that's kind
of what's happening now.
At the end of the day,
people come up to me,
they think that I work for those people,
they think that I work for these, I don't,
and it's just based
off of my association--
- Work with who?
- Like Supreme, Bape,
any of these streetwear brands
that basically have--
- They think they're feeding you?
- Basically
but it's me feeding myself
'cause I'm just dedicated to what I do.
- I couldn't agree more.
Never even crossed my mind
that you were with them like that.
You can win if you're
the best at what you do.
- Right.
And I think that at the end of the day,
I'm one of if not the best at what I do.
I'm definitely the most notable
of all the people that do what I do.
- And so here's what I would say,
everyday people tell me,
why the fuck do you tell
everybody the best shit for free?
And I'm like, because 99% of people
aren't gonna do anything about it
and there's an abundance.
One of the reasons psychologically
it would make sense for you to charge
is you know you're also creating
a supply and demand issue
that takes away your own advantage.
- I know of want to move up.
- Right, I'm telling you the move up
is to get as many people on as possible
and create no friction.
There's always gonna be something else.
I'm about to make K Swiss hard to get.
- It's literally what I
just said about the coat,
it's always gonna be something,
literally yes, I agree with that.
- The end.
The end, got it?
That's it.
The secret is the reverse
of what people think.
It's some Bible shit, they were right,
just give it all away for free,
get it all back.
- So you think I should go,
you think I should focus more--
- I think the biggest mistake
that smart people are making right now
is charging their audience.
And that's what's coming
to everybody naturally.
It's like music,
the music should be free,
that's how you make real money.
I would fucking,
I'm fucking yelling at people online,
BitTorrent my book if you can't afford it.
(laughing)
I'm happy that some kid
just heard me say that
and you're gonna keep it in the edit
and I want them to hear that because what?
I want him to win, I want her to win.
Do I lose money 'cause I just said that?
Yep.
Are some people that don't
even know what that is
and they just Googled it
and are like, oh shit, yes,
but I mean it.
- Right, 'cause you want people
to have that information.
- I didn't write the book
because I'm gonna make
the fucking bullshit four dollars per book
or whatever the fuck is
my cut with the publisher.
I wrote it because some people
learn better reading a book
than watching my fucking videos.
I fucking hated recording my audiobook.
I didn't record it for the
fucking couple more sales,
I recorded it because some people
don't want to read a fucking bullshit book
but they'll audio the fuck out of me
in two fucking gym sessions
and walking their fucking dog.
- Subway train, yep, ride home from work.
- The content is the magic,
it's the gateway drug.
I get 150,000 racks a talk
because I gave away my shit for free
while fuckers are trying to
sell $400 ebooks out there.
- That's what I want.
- Okay, well then you
better fucking listen.
- I'm listening, I'm all ears.
- You got it?
- Yep.
- How they want it, in every format.
I'm taking out all the costs.
How many people we got?
- [Mike] 20.
- I got 20 people on my team
helping me make content.
Why?
'Cause I'm gonna give it to you
in every fucking format,
audio, vlog, vlog on
YouTube, vlog on Facebook,
podcast, Google, Apple, Samsung,
Instagram, cool, Snapchat,
good, LinkedIn, yep,
Medium, good, my blog, yep, Twitter, yes.
What's everybody else doing?
They get a little bit of
a fanbase on Instagram,
they're like, good, I'm
good here, I'm good here.
Okay, that's it, that's fine.
What are you gonna do when
Instagram's not relevant?
Do nothing else but continue
to flip and make money
and give away everything you got
to everybody on social media at scale
in a way you've never seen.
I would tell you straight
up like straight up,
not only sell shit and make money
but take 90% of the profits
and pour it back into a team
and ads on social
to give away shit for free.
Listen to what I'm telling you,
make a million dollars,
make $100,000,
I have no idea how much
money you're making,
live worse than you did two years ago,
this is the official advice,
make the money you're making,
live worse than you did
before this started happening,
take the money, run Instagram and Snapchat
and Facebook and YouTube ads
for people to see the shit for free.
That's my official advice.
You're too young, that's why, you got time
and that advice is predicated,
if you're 98 year old Charlie
do not take that advice.
That advice is strictly for you.
You know what my career
is based on, Mike Boyd?
I didn't make that much money,
I built a fucking business for my dad,
I have no money.
I didn't own the business
so I didn't go to a bank and get a loan,
I wasn't making that much money
but I lived humble as fuck
and what did I do?
I saved the little I saved,
so I saved 13,000 this year,
9,000 that year, right,
finally had a little something,
and then Facebook and
Twitter came across my desk
and I fucking struck.
Had I with the little fucking money,
all these kids make more money than I did,
I'm being serious,
people don't understand,
people are like, oh, you had a liquor,
don't listen to him, he got a,
I built my parent's liquor
store for them, I got nothing.
- I remember you saying
that if you would've spent
the money for the clicks
that you were spending,
you spent eight to 10 cents then,
they're like eight to 10 dollars now
that you could've basically
made your parents liquor store
even that much bigger.
- 100,000%, 100%, 100%.
So I get worried
and the reason I'm ranting right now
is 'cause I think people
think I'm giving advice
from my perch now.
I'm giving advice I took.
People are trying to come up for excuses
to why not to work,
people are trying to come
up with excuses why to buy,
listen, you can buy off whites all day
if you can afford 'em.
But if you're buying the as the,
you've been saving up
or robbing somebody to get 'em, you lost.
- Totally, totally.
- And it's happening.
I'm saying it, you're saying,
it's unbelievable, we're 10 years away,
shit's gonna be so different, man.
Shit's gonna be so different.
It's already so different,
you guys are young, like I saw it,
hip hop was one thing,
you were tough, the end,
that was it, that's it,
there was no other thing,
guys, you couldn't do what
the fuck you were doing,
a bandanna on your leg, fucking shoot you,
there was one move, there was one move,
they were all the same person,
you were Timbos, you were Starter,
there was one move, everyone was the same
and if you weren't that,
you made up your story that you were.
If you had music skills
and you want to be a rapper
and you lived in the suburbs
but your aunt lived in the hood,
you visited one time in the hood
and that's where you said you were from.
- [Lavard] 'Cause then
nobody's gonna judge you.
- That's right
'cause there was no option.
Now all of you guys can do
whatever the fuck you want.
You're gay, good, trans, good,
fucking want to dress
like Jimi Hendrix, cool,
fucking look at you guys, it's the best,
it makes me so happy.
Now people can just be,
what can anyone do right now in hip hop
that's gonna feel that you can't?
Nothing, nothing.
You want to be Cardi B, good.
What are you gonna judge?
Nothing.
- That's what got me to this point.
You can't tell me shit
about what I'm trying to do.
- You're wearing a Tina Turner tee shirt.
- Yeah, she fire,
Private Dancer Tour 1985.
- She's the most fire
but you know, people don't
get it, it's the best,
hip hops the most accepting, the most.
I love it but just don't be confused,
you gotta make that successful,
you can't just say you're a rapper.
That's why sports was the best,
nobody's like, yo, I'm a basketball player
if they weren't in the league.
But music, I'm a rapper, yeah but--
- [Lavard] Only if you're making music,
oh, I made this song yesterday.
- But on the flip side, what's amazing
is on the flip side of
everything we're just saying
you are maybe just one
SoundCloud song away,
you are, that's crazy,
you are just one viral fucking video away
from being able to then
build a huge career
around music around it.
what are we living through?
- [Lavard] That's all
you need is one time.
- But you got to put yourself out there.
All these viral hits,
they made shit before.
That kid was around before,
it was just their time.
- Yep that's how I look at it.
I look at it like a recycling,
most industries go into a recycling step.
- 100%, 'cause you know why, my man?
'Cause humans are humans,
it's all the same shit.
There's only like nine or 10,
people are always like,
you're really good at Q & A,
I'm like, 'cause there's only 13 answers.
It's just psychology,
either you had too much
or you had too little,
either you love your parents
or you hate your parents,
next.
I can give you every answer after that.
What the internet did
was it allowed the ones
that didn't have as much
get the advantage,
that's what got fucked up
'cause we're hungrier.
And nobody's stopping us.
- And now you see is now
that you have to go outside,
people think that they can just
sit on the internet all day
and just do it.
- And they can.
But if you're really
smart and you go outside
and you do the internet.
- Double win.
- It's basically that saying
of not letting hard work,
well not letting talent
overshadow the hard work
or not letting people that work hard--
- You know what all those things are?
They're just talking about balance,
it's just balance.
It's just balance,
I haven't read the articles yet
but what McGregor did yesterday,
probably just went, like I don't know,
I'm still just reading headlines
but he probably just went too far
and then it's like, ah, fuck him.
- He definitely did.
- He did, right, what happened?
- He threw a barricade through the window
while the fighters was on the bus
and cut some dudes face up with the glass.
- Wait, huh?
- He crashed the press conference--
- Right, which is kind of like WWF, cool.
- McGregor shit, whatever,
but then it escalated out
into where the buses were,
he breaks through
security, grabs a barricade
and then throws the shit into a window,
you know how them tour buses is,
throws it through the tour bus window
in the back of the bus though
where everybody was sitting at
and it cut some guy,
three people can't fight
'cause of that shit.
- I know.
- One dude's face got all cut up,
he suffered like,
so he wild out,
like I can see you throwing
it at the luggage hold
or I want to get some rock,
no that's glass.
- What did he do that for though?
- 'Cause he didn't like
the other guys on the bus,
he might've been stripped to the title.
- No, he's hacking culture, he's smart,
he's smart.
If he didn't throw it through the window
and it just hit the back of the bus,
we'd all be like, he's
fucking a gangster, got it?
But it's all about balance
but 'cause it went through
the glass and then,
and now you're like nah.
Got it?
Balance.
- People that say, "Yo that was cool"
and there's other people
like, "No, that's messed up."
- And then the conversation starts.
- And that's when the
threads on Twitter go up
and that's when everybody on
the internet say something.
- What do you think in terms like
because at the end of the day,
I still want to be able to
like package this properly?
- I'm gonna explain.
- Oh okay.
- You're trying to play checkers,
I want you to play chess.
Packaging means monetizing
and I'm trying to make you
monetize in a different way.
You know what I mean?
Packaging this to monetize is fine
and by the way, you're more than welcome
but my theory is the
attention's worth more.
- That's what I mean.
- Well that's it, eliminate the friction.
Look what I do,
I eliminate the friction
between me and my audience,
I don't charge and I put it everywhere
in every shape and form, the end.
That's why I'm the ultimate,
I really believe that.
I'm the one that's
eliminating the most friction.
And by the way, also when
you're not asking for money,
it just changes the relationship.
- [Lavard] 'Cause it's mor genuine.
- Yeah, everybody's waiting
for my other shoe to drop.
I'm like, "Okay, cool,
we'll see how it plays out."
Now listen, I do things,
I have a sneaker with
K Swiss, I have a book,
I'll say buy
but I don't do anything
to make anybody get,
people do the content to make them buy,
you wouldn't have even realized it,
you wouldn't have even realized it
but everything you would've
done for free on social
would've had subconscious context
to get them to pay for the $200 thing.
- No I agree.
- The end, that's it.
For me, I'm happy to ask
buy my fucking sneaker,
I just don't give a fuck
if you do or you don't.
I don't require you to
and I don't produce content
or have meetings because,
got it?
People are like, "Gary
Vee, you got a book,"
I'm like, yes, am I
making you buy the book
to then get past the fucking
firewall to get to the content?
I have no idea if you're
buying the book or not.
Got it?
So what I want is I
want to keep your purity
so they fuck with you heavy.
- Even more 'cause that's
basically why people fuck with me.
- And the second you turn
that switch, they won't,
not to the same level.
25% go fuck yourself, I always knew it,
I knew that shit was gonna be that.
The other 25% consciously they're
like okay cool, cool, cool
and hey, let him get his but fuck him.
I mean that's real,
that's what the psychology is.
There's only 13 answers.
It might be seven, it
might be 14, I'm not sure
but I'm just throwing it out
there, you know what I mean?
There's just not that many answers.
Like whoever gives most to
the fucking audience wins.
That's why everybody loves
everybody in the beginning,
they're the purest.
Then the fucking hands get in the mix.
- So would you say with that strategy,
it's safe to say--
- I deal with it myself
'cause I do events in the city
and people try to tell me, they're like,
yo, charge $20, you'll make so much money,
you'll get all these people coming in
and I'm just like, I don't
want to charge them $20,
I want to charge them five dollars
and they're like, oh, but you're
not making that much money
and I'm like, it's not about the money.
- Until you're the most
important, the most connected
and Budweiser comes along and says,
"Yo, I got a million for you."
- Then you can still do it for free.
- You just got to, okay,
cool, now it's free
and people are getting free Budweiser.
- People aren't smart,
they're trying to monetize them,
I just want to love them,
everything else will work itself out.
First of all, I always know
how to make money without them.
Second of all, I understand
I'm gonna have everybody,
I'll figure out how to win.
When everybody in America loves me,
when the Jets go up for sale,
everybody's got a dollar for me,
that's how I'll buy it
if I can't do it myself.
That'd be some of the
craziest shit of all time.
Imagine I live my life
for the next 16 years
keep going like this,
whatever I make my little
but I come up $500 million short
and America comes up with
the other $500 million.
- [Male] That's amazing.
- I think so.
So that's why when
everyone's throwing cynicism,
heat at me, I'm like, I can't hear you.
- Oh yeah, I'm programmed like that.
- Listen, anybody who flips
has been programmed like that
because the game is dirty.
What you going to Marshall's for?
I don't know.
What you going to TJ Maxx for?
What are you going to Goodwill for?
'Cause I'm trying to make
money, mother fucker,
what are you doing?
What are you doing?
- I know where to spend that money
and get that double maximum
return on it, period.
I agree.
Like I said, I'm just trying to--
- No, no, I know what you're trying to do.
- No, I mean it's like what you said
in terms of like giving it away for free,
being relevant in terms
of your craft and shit,
people will love you more.
So I'm kind of at that point
where people love me
and I don't love them
'cause I do fuck with people.
- Listen to me, listen to me,
do you spend an hour a day literally
on live Instagram and Facebook
and just answer people's questions?
- No, but I spend an
hour a day answering DMs
'cause my shit be OD.
- Good, that's good.
So add another hour of fucking Facetime.
Do you do a random fucking
secret meetup with 80 people?
- Yep.
- Great, how many?
- When the weather is nice,
I try to do them shits as much as I can.
- Listen, by the way, I'm not judging,
I'm trying to get data.
How often?
How many times have you randomly said,
"In three hours, come
here and whoever shows up
"I'm just gonna spit fucking truth?"
- No, we was giving clothes away.
We did that shit like three,
four times last summer.
- Great, do it every day.
Here's what I'm saying,
everything that got you here, do more.
- Okay.
- What you're doing is,
this is what I tell everybody,
not much has changed Mike.
- [Mike] That's true.
- Like a lot has changed
and nothing has changed.
These are the same
fucking meetings, right,
they're just different people, man,
it's just the same shit,
the Mac Miller's and Wiz
Khalifa's and Nissey Hustles
went on to become superstars
and then some of them didn't
but it's all the same shit.
- [Mike] That's very true.
- For all the princes and frogs.
Some of the people you thought
were gonna be the biggest
stars of all time,
they got caught up.
Some of the people that
you weren't as sure,
they became the biggest.
Titty Boy had to change his name.
- He forever Titty Boy to me.
- [Mike] He just changed his name.
- Travis Porter I thought
was gonna be the biggest
thing of all time.
- Oh my God, yo, being from Atlanta,
I can truly tell y'all Travis Porter--
- Guys, guys, Travis Porter is the Migos.
- I just said that shit,
I truly believe that.
That's the first three man group.
- That was a big moment.
Tyler, I'm underrated, I'm underrated,
I've been trying to tell
people, I know you know,
they don't know, they don't know.
- [Neil] Look bro, that's
the first three man group,
you was just like, oh my
God, what's 'bout to happen?
- [Male] That was the jam of jam.
- Mike's so happy right now.
So anyway, listen, so back
to what that means for you,
do what I'm doing and you
will be so fucking big,
you will remember this meeting
for the rest of your fucking life.
Just give at scale.
Don't try to make a dollar
out of anybody who follows you
on the craft of this.
Teach them how to fish.
- Be fishers of men.
- Just keep teaching 'em.
- Jesus shit now, bro.
- But seriously man, honestly,
just keep teaching them
and then you continue to do your craft
and that will work in parallel
and amazing shit will happen.
The power is in the attention.
What do companies want with Cardii B?
- The fact that you got
everybody watching her.
- That's it.
And so whether that's 'cause you're pretty
or 'cause can you rap or ratchet
or 'cause you can dunk
or because you're thoughtful
or 'cause you, whatever
it is in the world,
it's all the same game at the end,
exactly what U2 does and
what Tiger Woods does
and what fucking the Migos do,
it's all the same game.
When it's all melted down,
it's just to how much time did you spend
paying attention to
period, end of story, done.
Sporting events are long,
why are basketball players
more important than football players?
'Cause you can see their whole face.
Like if I owned the NFL,
I would take helmets off now
and nothing to do with concussions.
I just want people to see
Von Miller's face more often.
Will it be different hitting?
Yes.
Would I give a fuck?
No.
'Cause football would be bigger.
You know why in Atlanta clubs
football players walk in with chains
with their numbers on it?
'Cause you don't know who they are,
you don't know who they are.
- [Neil] Yeah 'cause when
you see a basketball player--
- You know exactly who that is.
- Well even soccer, same shit,
being it's like the
biggest sport in the world,
they run around, do their
little poses and shit,
you can see who it is.
It's like glory.
- So do you understand?
- Yeah.
- So that's what you're
trading in, my guy, attention.
So basically I just spent all
my time working my face off
so I can make money other ways
so I can bring the most love
so I can get attention 'cause I earned it
'cause I'm bringing
value, the end, simple.
Create no friction.
Charging, friction, not being
on every platform, friction.
That's fucking truth.
- True 'cause people
try to tell me stop using Facebook
and I'm just like, "For what?"
- I'm fucking obsessed with Facebook.
- Why would I sit on Instagram
all day and do things?
I can do things on Twitter,
I can do things on Facebook.
- Do it all, all, all, all,
all, all, all, all, all
and when shit's not popping
that's when it's popping.
I'm obsessed with Snapchat right now.
- [Mike] It's crazy.
So many people got off Snapchat.
The only people I see on
Snapchat are him and Future.
So now I see everything Future posts.
- [Lavard] 'Cause once Rihanna
stopped messing with it,
everybody that mess with Rihanna was like,
"Yeah, we not using Snapchat no more."
Hey, you just built a big audience
for everyone else that does still use it.
- And guess what?
15 year olds are on there.
And guess what?
They'll be 25 in 10 years.
- [Lavard] And they'll be
watching that for 10 years.
- Oh, that's what I'm on.
That's my whole tweet--
- And guess what?
Sit down and get disciplined.
I can't write for shit.
Guess what?
Even before I had people helping me write,
write a post on LinkedIn,
write a business post,
you write a business post on LinkedIn,
change your whole game.
- [Male] There's people probably
looking for you on LinkedIn
and they don't even know who you are.
- There's not a single fucking person
who knows who he is on LinkedIn.
- What the hell is LinkedIn?
What is LinkedIn?
- LinkedIn originally started
as a place where you could,
it was a job platform
where people recruited,
but now people are putting content.
And so you there could go in
with more of your professor shit,
you go with a little more
culture flavor on Instagram,
you can go a little bit different on,
there's so much to do.
Where's your podcast out?
- Oh, I've got one
coming with Foot Action,
it's gonna be a streetwear podcast,
I'm gonna consult and
actually do a podcast
starting in the summer.
- But that's Foot
Action's podcast, my guy.
Where's your podcast?
- I ain't got one yet
but now that you put me onto this shit--
- Here we go, you see what I'm saying?
- Yeah.
- It's fun, right?
And listen, it's fun for me too
and I get different things
from the old man in the retirement home
who teaches me about life.
Listen, as somebody who thought
he was the smartest and
best of all time at 22,
experience fucking matters.
I couldn't give this at 22.
It's pattern recognition,
I did this shit, you got it?
I don't think I'm better or
smarter or OG or whatever,
I just think I lived longer,
you would've gotten here anyway,
I'm just trying to save
you some fucking time.
You know, like I don't feel special,
I'm just trying to help you,
just save you
a fucking few minutes.
- I'm actually 22.
- Where do you guys live?
- [Male] Brooklyn.
- I'm from Ohio originally though.
- Ohio or Iowa?
Ohio?
- Yeah.
- What part?
- Akron.
- Mmhmm, Jesus, you really love LeBron.
You have to, right, like you better.
You don't?
If I lived in Akron, I'd have loved,
I'd probably have a face
tattoo of LeBron's face
over my own face.
If I'm from Akron, my God,
I would literally like transform,
I'm white, it'd be weird,
people are like, that's some racist shit,
I'm like, I don't give a fuck, LeBron!
Seriously, in Ohio, you
never won any championship
and LeBron did, guys you
don't even understand,
it makes no sense, it's
fairytale some movie shit,
oh some kids gonna grow up in Ohio,
become one of the great
basketball players of all time
and end up on the Cabs,
leave, come back, win,
be down three one
against the fucking squad
that was the generational squad, fuck you,
LeBron's a movie seven times over.
By the way, he was, that was in the works.
I don't know what happened,
I don't know if Mike killed--
- [Lavard] Somebody killed it.
- Or they couldn't make
a deal, I don't know.
- [Neil] I know Mike killed that.
- It's really been interesting,
you know honestly, the one thing
especially in your culture,
the one thing, I'm gonna give you
a really interesting piece of content
for you to think about,
it's crazy where Jordans
are in culture right now.
You could've never told,
how long you been in the sneaker game?
- Since I could know what sneaker was.
- Could you have ever
imagined it being less,
not this relevant?
Like, it's relevant
but like so much has chipped away at it
in the last five years.
- There's just more fish in the sea now.
Jordan was like the only
go to when he was younger,
now it's more, remember I was telling you
about the lake that
you're in is different.
Now, you got Kanye, you got Virgil,
Nike's stepping up their stuff,
you got Big Sean got a shoe.
Jay Z, there's just so
much different stuff
in terms of like the
athletes gotta compete
with the entertainers now.
- [Neil] And I think this the first time
Adidas has ever had so
many shoes that come out.
- That's why Jordan went to Drake.
Like you just said, why
would a brand want Cardii B?
Because of the attention they could get.
Jordan knew what they was
doing when they went to Drake.
They went to Drake because he
was the most relevant rapper
at the time that was on fire.
- You gotta rock in five minutes
'cause you gotta see Helen
and you gotta go meet Finn.
- Great.
Nobody in the sneaker game
would've thought it
could've happened this fast.
This all happened in the last three years,
it happened real fast,
real fast, real fast.
- I was thinking, even
when I was in high school,
damn, Jordans, people
killing kids over Space Jams.
- [Lavard] Now you can get
a Space Jam for 80 bucks.
- There's not a single person
in this room wearing Jordans.
Three years ago, four out of five.
- You got lucky 'cause
I almost had a pair on.
- And listen, Jordans are,
listen, I've never owned a pair of Jordans
'cause fuck him but,
but, they're great sneakers
and they're still great and they play
and people wear them all day
but not really.
They were the only thing people wore.
- Yeah, that and Air Froces
and Tims, like you said.
- Yeah, I wore Air Forces
because I hated Jordan
and that was it, that's all I wore.
- I definitely remember those days.
- That's all I had.
- [Neil] I'm from East Saint
Louis originally so Forces--
- You're from where?
- [Neil] I'm from Saint Louis originally.
- [Mike] We know each other.
In fact, I know all these guys,
I've known these guys
for a very long time.
- [Gary] I know but what
about the Saint Louis part?
- I found that out later
'cause he's an Atlanta guy.
He told me he was from East Saint Louis
and I was like, damn,
that touched my heart.
- [Gary] What part are you from?
- I'm from Saint Louis.
East Saint Louis is Illinois,
it's much worse as far as economy.
- It sucks.
- [Gary] There's level of suck.
- [Neil] That's the
first time you can say,
there's truly a level
of sucking that goes on.
It sucks really bad
and then it just sucks a little bit.
- Yeah like Akron just sucked,
it wasn't really sucky, it was great.
- Jackie's from there.
- She's such an athlete.
- [Neil] No, East Saint
Louis is like the Brownsville
of Saint Louis.
It's like how you go
to Brooklyn, New York--
- Do you understand, man?
- Definitely.
- Got it?
I'm glad you came.
I'm real glad you came,
you know what I mean?
- Basically what you saying,
you kind of just confirmed
what I was already doing
and the same to them.
- But you were about to graduate
and that graduation is
actually the recession.
- So just chill and let it keep building.
- Think about how basic it is,
triple down on what fucking got you there
instead of doing something
completely different.
- No, it makes perfect sense.
- Oh, the streets fuck with you
and then you got put on
and now you're gonna big time the streets,
you fucking idiot.
How the fuck do you think you got there?
- No, I say that all the time,
that's basically what I say
but I also be feeling like,
so one more thing 'cause
I know you gotta go
but my thing is this though,
would you agree to say
that first to dictate
is he who determines
standard of said industry?
So if I'm the first person to be vocal
about what's being said,
do you think that that
will basically set the bar
for any copycats or
things that will follow?
- I think that there's a land grab
when you're first and
you're right that is great.
I think when it comes to the copycat,
it's just noise.
If you're better, you win.
If Kid comes along the way
and plays your blueprint
and he's better, she wins.
Sorry you're sad,
that's what fucking all this
angst in the rap game is.
- [Neil] Oh, you came and
started rapping like me?
Well, sorry.
- I'm sorry Lil Yonny
was in Arkansas State,
wherever the fuck,
and fucking did it.
I get it that you've been a fucking,
I get that you grew up in a
jazz home and this and that
but that's just the way it is.
It just is what it is,
like listen,
and by the way, honestly,
I don't think of it as hate or bitterness,
I just think it doesn't matter.
Like I don't think people understand,
I'm not looking at like
the old crowd and be like,
ah, that's not real music.
I don't like at it as hate.
I just don't think either
is right or it matters.
The market is the market is the market.
Everybody copies my shit,
I'm sure I copy other peoples',
that's not, what you're the first person
to talk about resale
culture on the internet?
Get the fuck out of here.
People were making garage
sale videos on YouTube in '06.
- That's all I was saying
like in terms of platform--
- But everyone's about themselves, right,
like kind of like, you're
not gonna be the first,
you're not gonna be the last.
- Just be the best.
I was already on--
- And just recognize that
when you're the best,
you just don't want to
end up Rocky three, right?
Because you're the best, you're the best,
and then you got robots
and then Mr. T punches
your fucking face off.
The reason I'm fucking working harder
and smarter and giving more
is I know I'm winning
which means I'm vulnerable.
- Basically, you did it
right on the head right here,
that's actually kind of how I feel.
- I get it.
- Oh, thank you.
- You're welcome.
Which is why I know that
because it's why you're smart,
you're saying, okay,
look I'm vulnerable now,
the information's gonna get
there, people are coming up,
you always know it, right,
it's like an athlete, back to sports,
you knew in that one kid,
you just saw something where some kid
was coming from even less than you
and is a little more,
and you're like, I know
exactly what that is.
You're like, that was me 24 months ago
and I know I can't beat that
'cause I got my off whites now,
I had a nice meal.
So you said, "Cool bet, I'm smart,
"I'm gonna start building a
different thing that scales."
I'm saying, "Exactly but go even higher."
- Okay.
- The end.
Experience, baby, right?
You'll be doing the same thing one day,
experience, man, fuck.
- Yeah 'cause I'm basically
I want to do what you do in my arena.
- You know what the best part
of being an entrepreneur is?
You don't get slow.
- Nope, not at all, you get smarter.
- Kobe got slower.
LeBron's gonna get older that's just life.
M.J. and the Wizards wasn't that same M.J.
But for me, I'm now 42, I'm
in the best, I'm in the prime.
What happens with entrepreneurs
is they get too rich
and then they start
trying using their money
to stop the young bucks.
Always pay attention to the
person that's giving the advice
not the advice.
You know who's telling
you to charge 20 bucks?
Non winning players.
- [Lavard] Yep, I already know that
and that's why I don't listen.
- So when people are like, "Gary,"
like sometimes in this
moment people are like,
"Yo but fuck, you're
saying the opposite shit."
I'm like, "Cool, who's
telling you the other thing?"
Now, now, if they're like, Diddy,
then I'm like,
okay well then you have
got to make a decision
'cause there's a million ways to win
but 99% of the time they're saying shitty
is giving me that advice,
you know what I mean?